الميدانيه قال موقع ريبار العسكري الروسيه
ان ميليشيا فاجنر سيطرت على بلده بروخكا
في ضواحي الشماليه لمدينه
وضاف الموقع ان السيطره على هذه البلده
سيمكن هذه القوات من قطع احد اهم طرق
امدادات الجيش الاوكراني وكان قائد
ميليشيا فاجنر يفغيني بريغوجين قد ظهر في
مقطع مصور وهو يتفقد مواقع قواته فيما قيل
انها الاحياء الشرقيه من باخموت
من جانبها قالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
انها تصدت لهجمات روسيه في مناطق عده
باقليم دومباس شرقي اوكرانيا خصوصا في
بخموت واضافت قياده الاركان ان قصفا روسيا
عنيفا استهدف بلدات في محيط المدينه ونقل
مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه
ان ميليشيا فاجنر كثافتها هجماتها على
المحور الشرقي لباخموت رغم تكبدها خسائر
بشريه وماديه كبيره على حد وصفها